unless is with us in Kentucky welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Alyssa guys thank
you so much thank you how can I help all
right
so my husband and I we have two young
children around baby step two we have a
growth income of about forty four
thousand a year he's a teacher and at
the rate that her young family is
growing we were kind of wondering
whether we should pause our that
snowball to say that for a minivan or
just keep paying on debt until the third
baby comes so what have you got now
well come try what car you got now we
have like a Toyota Camry it feeds about
five but we can't put a car seat in the
middle because it's not sort of to do
that so it doesn't have a seat belt in
the middle doesn't okay
what's the Camry worth and maybe twenty
five hundred okay well if you want to
try it for a twenty five hundred our van
I don't care you know I guess we're just
worried cuz um you know we do have two
young kids and my husband mostly is just
worried about the safety of the van that
cheap he's driving a car that cheap with
two kids that's true okay I mean I don't
want you to drive junk the rest of your
life but you cannot use the fact that
you have three kids is an excuse for
being broke lots of people with three
kids aren't broke and so and you can't
use it as rationalization and
justification for buying stuff that you
can't afford so I'd love for you to get
a better van but it's going to involve
him working more other than just his day
job he's probably gonna pick up a side
job and you know here's an example
here's an unpleasant example okay mm-hmm
he delivers pizza four nights a week
which makes you a very fatigued mother
of small children okay because he's not
home enough he does that for a year
it makes $1,500 a month 1500 times 12 is
18,000 that'll buy a nice van
mm-hmm so how bad do you want a van
that's the thing okay
maybe you want a $9,000 van because
maybe you only want him to do that for
six months maybe he's a teacher so he
starts doing tutoring on the side I'm
making 25 bucks an hour more than he
would make delivering pizza but still
he's gonna have to be working more to
create more income if you want to move
up in car and do some of the stuff
because what you're telling me is your
budgets tight and I think it's realistic
that your budgets tight but here's
here's what you have to be very very
careful of I am the father of two
daughters both of which have small
children I see the fatigue in their eyes
a group of small wild animals will drain
the blood out of your body okay
I mean that's what happens it's fatigue
it goes with the territory of having you
know three kids four and under you know
it's just like buh and they sound like
little pterodactyls you know they they
can break your eardrums it's just it's
part of the deal it you don't even
realize you're getting tired because
you're just being a mommy and you're
being a good mommy but in the middle of
that tired you cannot get your let
yourself
drive off the road of wisdom into the
road of foolishness and go buy a van you
can't afford or or set yourself up to
wear well because we have small children
we can't do anything now that's not true
you can do these things but you just
have to start carving out time and the
ability to pay for it so I suggest we
work on getting your elves in come up
and I suggest we get you on a budget to
every dollar budget for free make the
money that you have work even harder and
then let's talk about saving up a couple
thousand dollars adding it to that Camry
buying a $5,500
van and in cash and then let's get this
debt paid off so we can get back to the
savings mode and then if you want to
move up in van a little bit more later
on that would be a reasonable way to do
it when our children were little they
were driving they were riding around in
cars the same prices your car and they
all made it
they're in their 30s